a cair em balé balé da ai para encontrar
o antigo hoje em falar sobre turismo e
sustentabilidade
e como é que o turista qual a contribuir
para ser um campeonato que exige pensar
lançada de saber que tem gente que tem o
que a gente sonha um punhal a 88 anos
[Música]
que emprega uma em cada dez pessoas e
movimenta milhões do que nós
nossas assinados sem recorrer a manter
as necessidades das gerações futuras e
não de maneira prática como e futurismo
atua exatamente da mesma forma é através
de pragas e de ações que beneficiam o
prazo os sulistas as unidades e uma
mangueira principalmente cuca também são
locais e e o problema são os maiores e
os russos justiça existe e se
desenvolver
então agora aqui fica a lista não é
estupro pela turista nacional e na
turística
as chances de o do turismo
já vi isso no luxo e desembarque
aproximado o turista ando do próprio
setor
o turista foi visto como uma residência
e se encontrava no tinha em viagem de
lazer
xuxa posteriormente o serviço ou fora
dos eua william e vibrava com o
conhecido tio yang a viagem foi vista
com ao ceará até hoje por exemplo o
turismo responder essas e ensinados
futurista é através de uma oferta de
experiências memoráveis e autênticas com
chá todos nós temos 11 tinha que fazer e
como fazer esforço que existe entre ijuí
nesse sentido sendo que somos nós que
achamos nós deslocamos para terminar
sítio do profissional vizinho
[Música]
o que muda com rocha as
responsabilidades se você quer também
uma responsabilidade para com seu amigo
o turista é da maneira que pode
contribuir também precisamos pensar fora
da caixa e da nossa zona de conforto
deixando nós podemos contribuir para o
turismo mais sustentável
muitas vezes falo com a 1 com 11
guinchos
o júri junho e como é comum também serão
adotadas planejarmos que contributos ele
nós fomos lá para os cinco anos o que
mostra disposta a definir um banco à
chávez e muitas vezes o que o isso eu já
passei tanto tempo para fazer essa
viagem eu vou pensar em poupar outra vez
não foi bem e falei para entender que
tudo que ela tem grandes disputas da
nossa viagem estamos vendo um vídeo
porque nenhuma das minhas filhas feira e
não vão conseguir porque é muita gente
a comissão de juristas responsáveis de
alguns exemplos
quando nós procuramos xuxa tutinho ser a
nossa linha de cuidado perceber quais
são as necessidades deste ano
se eu quiser fazer cessar o iraque para
mim sabe conseguir vir para nis número
de graus
o saco fu fugir uma época do ano entre
média ou baixa e dessa forma eu sou
contribuir para a quebra das ruas
dominadas local
sabe eu saio com ações em sinal de que o
local tem será que eu vou sentar por
exemplo pela venda de todos os anos os
abençoe os cuidados embutir no local que
é uma reserva da biosfera
[Música]
um exemplo da capacidade de carga que
associados e aqui também ao caso dos
problemas será que alguma mesa ou ser
agoniza no carnaval
sabendo que ia processar a tunísia já
está mais do que ultrapassado orçamento
e também procurar outras formas como é
que eu vou deslocar
será que eu tenho uma preocupação ou a
pegada que o time que eu exerço aufiram
terminar se transforma em 2050
[Música]
iam 36% foram efetuadas postada 4% por
mar e 2% é de cowboy se podem obrigou
essas pessoas obrigatoriamente 6 56% das
pessoas que foram campeão goiano leão
conhecido nossa viagem impacto ambiental
por exemplo e mesmo dentro do movimento
e quando eu penso banda nossa mente que
o planeta terra é de 13 por cento a 90
sobre o formato o diu não ser 1,3
torcido na água potável é preciso
conhecer bilhões de pessoas no planeta
será que eu devo pensar nos todos nós
podemos ser turistas que contribuem para
o turismo não é só o ecoturismo por
exemplo que tem
figas e ferraduras todos nós podemos rir
e adotar práticas que contribuem para o
turismo sustentável e em 2007 no ano
internacional para um turismo
sustentável
desenvolvemos uma campanha e se chama
chegou em joy e 7 que lhes foram pessoas
falando em português terá em as devidas
dicas de turismo responsável e nós vamos
ver quais são as indicadas muitos erros
que esta campanha promoveu para em gross
turistas poderão assim nessa forma
contribuir para a sustentabilidade no
turismo
conto viagem
saio nossas pesquisas sobre o local
sobre as normas do caras sobre o que une
diferentes e o nosso grande espetáculo
nós queremos tirar uma fotografia este
ano o qual devem se intensificar a
pressão para tirar a fotografia por da
mesma maneira que ele vá nossas vidas
silva entre nelson lentas proteja o
nosso poeta consuma o nome de água
energia possível
e também se for um espaço de 50 da
oferta sobre as ruínas o estágio tem
esse cuidado também não ir para locais
que são dados a aceitação local com
produtos locais foi também ao pagar um
preço justo por esses produtos será um
produto é roxy 3 ser que estivesse
sentindo feliz vamos informar sobre
saúde e segurança
vamos informar será também está em
práticas sustentáveis group seja
respeitoso como lembrança e quando
voltar de uma viagem de viagens próximas
[Aplausos]